on change pas de sujet on reste avec
françois valéry qu'une personne il
savait qu'il était pas [ __ ] comme une
bête qui était pas un alphabet qu'il
était né en raw qui s'appelait jean
louis mon journée alors valoir françois
valéry bonsoir bonsoir j'ai vu un film
qui s'appelle freddie 4 et en première
partie disons à voir la pub tu es un
clip de toi absolument insensé août qui
s'appelle esclaves de la musique où tu
fasses un peu un coup changement comme
sarah jackson thriller où tu veux te
dire l'autisme blanchi a pas de raisons
que l'on sait par six voix là tu te
noirci complètement cirque eta la fin tu
veut tellement être noir que tu te mets
de la boue
ouais oui parce que bon c'est le site
une chanson qui fait un transfert c'est
quelqu'un qui font grossir complètement
saoul peuples noirs à la musique gospel
j'ai fait ce qui passe le lead est
intéressant à ce niveau là haut
sur la gueule parce que c'est vrai quand
il enterre ses guitares et voilà donc ce
que ça c'est pas un peu une façon de
faire scandale comme ça qu'on voit
françois bayle eric et grimages un peu
20h30 après j'entends dit la semaine
dernière que tu as déclare une fois oui
acheter mais disent je sais ça fait un
peu bête
c'est vrai ça fait quoi encore mais sa
palette longtemps le symbole comme ça
le chanteur showbiz un peu chanteur pour
minettes lyonnais propres et gentillet
mais on sait pas grand chose de toi
mais parce que tu t'appelles comment
jean-louis boujon
d'après françois parce que c'était
mitterrand et valérie parce que j'espère
des intervenants pas si je suis un peu
comme ici quoi et je crois beaucoup en
voyant tous ces trucs là et c'est une
voyante qui m'a donné ce nom là sans
bouger les tables ouais ça marchait dis
donc tu t'appelles comment alors bonjour
jean louis jean louis mougeot ouais
voilà bon temps sur nos maintenant bien
sûr non comment elle tu appelles leur
intimité
françois a bon fond mais pas mon gros
poussin bientôt signer un bébé ça c'est
gentil alors anthropologie rapidement
comme est une mesure check point m 112
fois grand c'est ce qu'ont bien là j'ai
maigri je près 68 kg je mérite ce qu'il
est dans ça va ça va bon alors les
cheveux pas tu n'es pas blanc si je suis
bon mais je fais des petites neiges ce
qui n'était pas besoin des polders et
est sûre c'est la vraie couleur de
cheveux
les yeux sont marron c'est ça les signes
particuliers opérations non cet ouvrage
non cicatrices j'en ai une dans la tête
j'ai pris un coup de bouteille sur la
tête un jour
ouais en faisant quoi
nous battant
j'ai une cicatrice là un coup de couteau
la d'accord maladies chroniques
allergies non tu feras des implants
quand tu seras plus âgé des liftings et
trucs comme ça
pourquoi pas juste pour moi non pourquoi
pas je pourquoi pas tu diras pas où tu
lui diras ce catherine lara elle le dit
peut-être est bien né en algérie ça je
savais pas tenir ou en algérie à oran
c'est vrai que par l'espagnol portée des
toutes les mères nous parle espagnol et
par un tout petit peu espagnol parce que
tu sais en algérie avait il ya beaucoup
de colonies espagnoles et par contre du
côté d'alger cédé contre l'italie alors
un jour c'est assez à sa préquelle seul
mais c'est dur un jour tu as dit il faut
y aller pour partir c'était en 62 matchs
six mois j'ai connu si tu veux vraiment
le départ d'algérie
j'ai tellement que j'avais 8 ans mais
j'ai connu si tu veux vraiment le
stéréotype de la du débardage jerry
c'est-à-dire avec ma mère et mes soeurs
d'arriver en france les valoches et où
j'ai vraiment connu ça et si tu veux bon
sur le coup je réalisais pas j'ai
réalisé plus tard
chose plus tard j'ai pris de faire parce
qu'il s'est cassé quand j'avais l'âge de
4 ans c'est un truc qui m'a marqué après
qui m'a marqué après surtout quand j'y
suis retourné et j'ai chanté j'ai
surtout avec ma mère j'ai chanté à alger
de deux soirs et quand j'ai fait une
chanson qui s'appelle laurent 62 les
musiciens un peu peur ou est avec
admirable pendant deux soirs qui était
froide saeki qui s'appropriait un petit
peu françois valéry quels sont tes
rapports aujourd'hui avec les lézards
après tu france parce que finalement on
pourrait dire le fait que les arabes en
france justifie rétais trouvé qu'ils
étaient français en algérie
moi je m'entends vachement bizarre hein
laissez moi je n'ai pas souvenance de
du racisme en haïti je suis connue on a
connu hier à six mois j'ai connu de
raciste parce que quand j'arrive je me
souviens quand je suis venu d'algérie à
l'âge de 10 ans je me suis et on me
disait beaucoup ça le pied-noir tour et
compagnie ça déconne il faut qu'il a
connue ici en arrivant ouais alors tu as
dit aussi j'ai une certaine culture j'ai
rien de neuf à bet on prend toujours
pour en alphabet c'est vrai nom cyrill
c'est vrai qu'on a tendance à prendre
les chanteurs dit populaire pour des
cons je suis pas spécialement quand la
france par la source de la loire par
exemple plus et où c'est non mais c'est
pas il sait pour moi c'est un critère de
415 tu connais quoi mais quand même -
ouais et la source de la loire tu sais
je connais les comprends qu'elles
étaient logés revient des gens si jamais
été très fort en chine par tu fais de la
musique de film si ça les gens le savent
mois il yad'ailleurs johnson qui a dit
nous en amérique on à quincy jones en
france vous avez en france vous avez
rejoint valérie sera énorme
à mon avis il a déconné vous êtes un peu
amoureux et amoureuses de toi
à déconner mais de musique de film et
j'ai la lune x contre toi et moi j'ai
donné mon coeur j'essai prête un énorme
tronc non ça est un triomphe et te dire
pourquoi
ouais parce que si tu vois il s'habille
ça va me connaissez pas très bien la
route de ceux de cette pop star moi je
voyais tout bien au début c'était un
mélange pour moi de tina turner de
streisand et lui savait pas trop tu t'es
drogués jamais jamais un jour on m'a
fait que fumer un pétard
y at-il exprimé
s'est pas montrée d'arrêter là c'est
assez tourné la tête ça ne s'est pas
montré je préfère boire deux trois
verres de whisky te sers toi
ouais alors l'amour maintenant abbas
était une femme remarquable c'est vrai
nous cette rencontre et comment avec
nepal capture je te raconte tu peux
comme ça et ça sera pas du ici paris un
jour il y avait 1 c'était l'anniversaire
d'un copain moi qui ai un restaurant qui
s'appelle le gorille et puis ça
m'emmerde et d'y aller alors je dis à
denis mon attachée de presse et amie
surtout tu ça m'emmerde il me dit tu
sais tu peux pas faire ça c'est un
excellent jeudi mais qui a quand même
dit qu'il était mis à nicole calfan
johnny la naccima serait de faire bouger
alors j'ai dit je viens mais tu me la
faut à matam
j'ai eu un coup de mou et si tu as un
coup de foudre de sa part parce que moi
je vous dis
qu'on cesse comme ça
c'est ce que je vois qu'on trouvera dans
paris match un peu se pose c'est vrai
elle communie français - chanteur
jeux populaires
et jeudi une phrase ou jeudi parce que
on s'emmerdait un peu j'ai dit on serait
tellement bien
elle t'a dit pourquoi pas ouais c'est
charmant mais c'est pas ici paris la cdc
les biotech rose donc c'est donc c'est
un peu elle guitare je veux dire à tes
dragueur toi comme j'aime beaucoup les
femmes pas les jeunes filles femmes
telle argue la tullaye les pépés où tu
te fait larguer ou comment ça se passe
bien si je te dis que j'ai cru qu'en
principe ce jeu là tu va me prendre pour
un prétentieux mais c'est vrai en
principe ça se passe comme ça
côté pieds-noirs peut-être un peu non
cotées seront aussi des jaloux tu vas
aussi un maghreb à la maison les
seychelles
mais tu sais moi j'ai une femme à part
moi j'ai une famille c'est ma soeur ma
femme mariée
pudique au mec ou malades et après la
maison peut nous dire ah ouais je me
balade à paul parce qu'il ya des gens
devant le petit nom en face devant le
petit messi quand je prends mon bain il
vient me voir mais
je peux pas me balader à poil parce qu'à
la bonne parce qu'à l'heure ce jeu je
peux pas bon dernière que sa banque
comment rester là avec le physique que
tu as est ce que tu as déjà eu des spas
des tentations homosexuels des
expériences homosexuelles je vais te
dire un truc voilà grâce à juge unique
je vais te dire un truc j'ai un
collaborateur qui homosexuels
complètement et qui me dit tu sais mon
pauvre france qu'il a toutes les
qualités sont celles là et pour être sûr
de ne rien rater de dinars 10 tubes
abonnez vous je m'étais un peu ce bleu